Mike Brazil: My name is Mike Brazil.
I'm an associate manager in finance operations
on Google Checkout.
And it's my pleasure to welcome Brett Johnson
today as part of our Leading@Google series.
For those of you who may not be familiar with
the series, it's designed to bring in experts
from around the world to help us learn about
leadership and how we can apply it to our
unique context here at Google.
Just to give you a little bit of background
on Brett.
Brett Johnson is the founder and current president
of the Institute for Innovation, Integration
& Impact.
That's a Silicon Valley think tank that specializes
in aligning corporations behind a compelling
purpose that then drives innovation and results
in sustainable impact.
The Institute works with leaders and corporations
to discover their-- and implement personal
and corporate callings in order to have a
positive effect on society.
Previously, Brett was a partner at KPMG Peat
Marwick and Computer Sciences Corporation.
Before that, he spent 14 years at Price Waterhouse
working in United States and South Africa.
He has worked extensively with leaders around
the world and is the author of "LEMON Leadership:
Radically Fresh Leadership," which he'll be
speaking about today.
His first book, "Convergence," looks at issues
of work/life balance and the integration of
all facets of life.
Brett coauthored "I-Operations: the Impact
of Internet on Operating Models" with Gary
Daichendt, the former EVP of Worldwide Operations
at Cisco Systems.
He also has a few handful of books in the
works.
When life gives you lemons, you write a book.
And he'll let us know more about his book.
I'd like to welcome Brett Johnson.
Thank you.
[applause]
Brett Johnson: Thanks very much, Mike. Appreciate
the introduction.
Today, I'll be chatting with you a little
bit about LEMON Leadership.
And I will take questions at the end, although
I'm happy to be interrupted.
I was wondering, "What if there were more
than just two types of leaders?" [laughter]
And you can do the search yourself.
Some of you will be tempted to do it now.
But, the reality is, there are many descriptors
of leaders out there.
For years and years, I worked in executive
information systems starting about 30 years
ago.
And our challenge was to design systems that
were tailored to the way individual executives
were wired.
And so, we try to get inside their heads and
then figure out what would work for them and
wouldn't work.
But at the end of the day, when you went to
the body of literature that was out there,
you would have descriptors of "dogs" and "otters"
and, you know, "Labradors" and all sorts of
stuff like that.
And of course, the DISCs and the Myers-Briggs
stuff.
But, it all boiled down to two things: Managers
-- this guy doesn't work at Google -- and
Entrepreneurs.
And occasionally, you might find a third category
of person, which was what we'd call a "Visionary."
And a "visionary" in Silicon Valley -- as
you know -- is basically somebody who has
great ideas, but when the company gets going,
you stick him in a corner office, you feed
them the food under the door, and you hope
that they don't come out and disrupt things.
So, you know, when you looked at the literature,
basically it was entrepreneurs and managers
is what you are left with.
But, in my dealings with leaders, I found
that that just wasn't enough in terms of the
categories of people.
So I began to do some research -- work with
people, understand their characteristics -- and
determined that there are actually five types
of leaders.
Now here, I'm not talking about styles.
I'm not talking about preferences.
I'm not talking about introvert or extrovert,
or whether they are direct or indirect -- concrete
or abstract.
I'm talking about how they're wired -- Leadership
DNA.
And my contention is that there are not just
two, but five styles.
"Luminaries" lead with ideas primarily.
They see the world through constructs of thinking
thoughts long-term.
"Entrepreneurs" are driven by opportunities.
And "Managers" are driven by policies, procedures,
systems, structure.
They understand organizational capital, whereas
the Luminaries understand intellectual capital,
and Entrepreneurs -- real, hard capital -- finances,
assets, and so on.
Then, you get "Organizers" and "Networkers,"
and I'll chat a little bit about those.
But these five types of leaders.
In each one of us is a combination of these
five slices of the lemon, if you like.
Now, I'll put your mind at rest -- for the
Managers in the room.
I was teaching this out of the university
in Hawaii many years ago.
And some guy came in the next day, and he
said "I have just one problem with your model."
I said, "What is it?" He said, "It should
be called MELON Leadership."
I said, "Let me guess -- you're a Manager,
right?" [laughter]
And, yeah. I'll explain why the Managers are
in the middle in a moment.
So it's LEMON Leadership -- not MELON Leadership,
not VENOM Leadership, as if we had Visionaries,
you know, instead of Luminaries.
But mostly, we'd be left with Entrepreneurs
and Managers.
And the sad part about that -- if you remember
the book, "The E-Myth" -- there are many people
who think they're Entrepreneurs, but they're
not.
So if you look in college campuses, about
75 percent of people at college campus say
they're going to start their own business,
and down into 30 percent do.
And so, "The E-Myth" says, "There's not that
many entrepreneurs."
In fact, you might be interested to know,
"What are the percentages?"
And you guys are pretty data-driven.
So, here's the results -- globally first -- and
then, I'll give you the Silicon Valley split,
as to what percentage we see out there based
on thousands of assessments of Leaders.
So world population -- 9% are Luminaries.
When you get the combinations, like "What
percent are Luminary/Organizers?" for example
-- primary Luminary, secondary Organizers
-- the numbers will drop lower.
But 9% are Luminaries.
Then, about 14 percent only are Entrepreneurs
-- pretty small number.
Then, Managers are about 22 percent.
And Organizers -- 35 percent. And Networkers
-- 20 percent.
The interesting thing about this is that,
in traditional leadership literature, we're
missing half of the pie.
Organizers and Networkers are not even classified
as Leaders usually.
So, we need to see why that's a problem.
Here in Silicon Valley, we have slightly higher
percentage of Luminaries, [laughter] which
is good.
And then, we have not much difference in the
Entrepreneur quotient, which is quite interesting.
Of course, there's a confluence of factors
here with the universities, venture capital,
and so on -- that cause the Entrepreneurs
to have a better likelihood of success than
if they were elsewhere in the world.
But the percentage-wise is not much different
-- 1 percent different.
We have a higher degree of Managers over here.
Fewer Organizers and a lower number of Networkers.
Those are the guys who are in New York calling
you at night when you're having your meal.
That's where the Networkers are.
So, you might say, "We have more nerds than
nice guys" in Silicon Valley.
But, as the saying goes, "The geeks shall
inherit the earth."
So, that shouldn't be a problem.
So let's look at this a little bit more.
Of course, the issue is, "What do we do about
the missing percent?"
So, LEMON is fresh. It's a little bit different.
It's not about styles. It's not about what
your style is.
It's also not about your strengths and how
do you just make the most of your strengths
or your weaknesses and how to avoid your weaknesses.
It's also not about what you do under pressure.
So LEMON Leadership is radically different,
and we'll get into a that in a moment.
So firstly, throughout the book, we have these
LEMON truisms scattered.
And one of them is that you lead from your
identity -- not from your function, not from
your personality, not from your style so much,
or even your role.
Although it is possible for your role to squeeze
you a particular way.
I'll give you an example.
I was down the road at a semiconductor company,
shall we say, and most of the people in the
room -- directors, vice presidents -- indicated
that the CEO was a Luminary/Entrepreneur,
which he was.
And they were paid just to do stuff.
They weren't paid to think, basically.
But when we got their LEMON assessments results
back, they had a smattering of people.
And it took me about a half a day to convince
them that they could do more than just implement
what the CEO thought about last night.
And so, sometimes our function -- or our role
-- will squeeze us into a particular way
of operating.
But here's another truism -- "If you work
in a manner where who you are is consistent
with how you're wired on an ongoing basis,
you'll burn out."
So we have to watch out for that.
What I'm going to do is, there's a chapter
on each of these characteristics -- Luminaries,
Entrepreneurs -- and so on.
But I'm just going to give you a summary right
now of all five.
And chat through those at just the high level.
This is just an abstract of some of the things
that are out of the book.
So first -- and this is by the way -- each
of these on a good day.
Each of us has good days and bad days.
And here's a difference between LEMON Leadership
and other leadership stuff that I've read.
If, for example, you're going with color coding
and you're a red leader, under pressure, you're
bright red.
You know, you're burning red.
With LEMON Leadership, what I contend is that,
on a good day, you have the positive aspects
-- the strengths of your primary slice.
On a bad day, you will exhibit the negative
characteristics, or the weaknesses of your
secondary slice.
So these are the lemons on a good day.
And we'll look at them on a bad day in a moment.
So Luminaries -- they lead with ideas.
They have sayings like, "Ideas Have Consequences."
There was a Chinese chap and a Frenchman on
a plane flying.
And the Frenchman said to the Chinese guy,
"What do you think of the French Revolution?"
The Chinese guy said, "Too soon to tell."
Right?
Luminaries have long-term thinking.
Think about long-term consequences.
And they can -- on a good day -- blend their
passion and their principles.
So they will connect with people -- the person
might be missing part of their faculties,
but if they connect on ideas, they connect.
And so, Luminaries embrace people who have
the same sort of ideas as them.
At a "hands" level, they can do stuff well
first time.
Second time, not so good. Third time, bit
of a disaster. Okay.
The Entrepreneurs -- we know a lot about Entrepreneurs,
but they're driven by intuition and opportunities.
They are action-oriented. They can pull stuff
together early on.
And they generate a lot of excitement.
You've probably met people here in Silicon
Valley who will move from one company to the
next just following an Entrepreneur.
"What's he or she doing? I don't know, but
I'm going, because I think it's going to be
fun."
Entrepreneurs are sometimes more heat than
light, but still, people want them, they love
them, and they can get stuff going.
Managers. Managers are the folks that people
love to hate.
But the reality is, many of the corporations
-- the bigger corporations -- are run by
Managers.
That's what keeps the board happy.
That's what keeps things stable, if you want
a "Steady Eddy" kind of environment.
So, Managers -- they're good at long-term
planning.
They're patient.
You can give them a mess, and they can fix
it -- doesn't faze them.
They understand the competencies that are
needed.
While a Manager is building a team, an Entrepreneur
and Organizer is just doing it themselves.
But the Manager's thinking, "I don't want
to have to do this a year from now."
So they'll slowly build a team to get something
done.
And some people say that, "Managers have no
heart."
That's not true.
They connect with people through consistency.
It might not be the brilliance of the Luminary,
or the excitement of the Entrepreneur, but
through consistency.
These are the folks who actually do your annual
reviews on time.
The other guys don't necessarily do it.
You know, they'll talk about it, they'll think
they've done it if they're a Luminary, they
imagine they did it. [laughter]
They sold somebody else on doing it, like
Huckleberry Finn.
But Managers do it themselves.
So let's chat about Organizers and Networkers.
Organizers are highly intuitive.
And here's the challenge with Organizers.
They're hard to spot because of their high
level of intuition.
They just do stuff. Give them an objective.
Don't tell them how to get there. Get out
of the way.
"An objective plus permission" is what they
like.
And they don't like the rules, the structure,
or the stricture of the Managers, because
they can see how to do it without having to
read the manual.
And so, they're highly instinctive.
And they can also spot what's going to go
wrong.
So you can put something in front of them,
and they'll say, "It's not going to work."
And you ask them why, and they'll say, "I
don't know -- it's not going to work."
Now, actually, in a moment, I'll mention -- let
me just talk about it now.
When you'll see the Networkers -- the Networkers
are highly intuitive around people.
They can come into a room, and they can look
out and they can see who's getting it, who
isn't getting it, who's connecting.
They're great communicators. They're kind
of chameleons.
In the first edition of the book, there's
a section on "How to Communicate with Different
Lemons" -- how to adjust what you say, the
pace of what you say, the medium of what you
say.
With Networkers, there's no advice for them,
because they do it automatically.
It took some people awhile to figure that
out.
So in the second edition, I've explained why
that's the case.
I didn't forget to finish the chapter.
Networkers just know how to communicate.
And the cool part about the Networkers is,
they make you feel like you're their best
friend.
For example, a friend of mine was CFO out
at Sears, and John Chambers from Cisco went
to see him.
And he says, "Chambers makes you feel like
you're the only customer," right?
And you know it's not true, but you still
kind of feel good when he comes around.
Speaking about Chambers for a moment, you'll
notice what happened with Cisco -- they got
to a stage in their business where they had
gaps in their product line.
And Chambers was the next perfect CEO, because
all he did is, he went out and acquired companies
to fill the holes in the product architecture.
And he could do a billion-dollar deal before
you'd buttered your toast in the morning -- a
lot of out of instinct and high networker.
So Networkers make you feel like their best
friend.
Of course, they have 279 best friends.
They think that they're all actually their
best friends.
If you go on their Facebook, they're up in
the thousands over there.
Actually, we ran a LEMON Assessment recently,
and a guy from Microsoft came to me, and it
showed up that he was something like a Manager
or an Entrepreneur or a Luminary.
And he came to me, and he said, "I think I'm
a Networker. I think I'm a Networker."
I said, "Look. The scores are accurate. You're
not a Networker."
"But, I have more than a thousand friends
on Facebook," he said.
I said, "Let me go over."
So I took him over to some real Networkers,
and I said, "Is this guy a Networker?"
They looked at him, and they said, "No, you're
not a Networker." [laughter]
Networkers know who the Networkers are. Okay.
What I was going to say was a little bit about
product development.
In product development, there's often arguments
about who's on point: Is it engineering?
Is it marketing? Is it sales? Is it development?
Who's carrying the ball at any point in time?
You can scrap all of that so long as you follow
the LEMON sequence.
You've got to have Luminaries involved up
front.
Then, Entrepreneurs to figure out if anybody's
going to buy this thing.
Then, Managers to actually work on the build.
Then, Organizers to see what's going to go
wrong.
So you put them in the test function.
They like to break stuff.
And Networkers to see if anybody will buy
it.
Doesn't matter which department they come
from.
I'll give you a practical example.
A company in South Africa was asked to put
together a curriculum around HIV/AIDS for
the government in South Africa.
And they were given the project with a fairly
short timeline.
Now, ordinarily, what they would have done
is, take a manager, get the project manager,
begin to build out the team.
And it would have been a long project.
It would have been about a 4-month project
by their estimate.
What they decided to do, because they'd come
to understand LEMON Leadership was, switch
things around.
And immediately, they put a Luminary on the
team.
And the Luminary scanned through lots of other
curriculum that was out there -- with an Entrepreneur.
So they had a Luminary and an Entrepreneur
first.
Then, they got a Networker to see if the rough
ideas would be bought by anybody.
Then, they added their Manager to bring stability
to the team, and they delivered the project
in seven-and-a-half weeks.
And the client said they'd never seen anything
like that before.
So just getting the right mix makes a huge
difference.
Moving along. This is a quote from a guy who's
a Manager.
You can see by the length of the quote, it's
not a very whiz-bingy kind of quote.
He's a nice guy, but he's a Manager.
You know, when he got married, he had a spreadsheet,
you know?
The potential fiancŽe -- she had to kind
of get the scores up, and it was a systematic
approach.
Okay. [laughter] All right.
Doesn't sound romantic, but she is married.
Okay.
Let's talk about the weaknesses.
On a bad day, the Luminaries narrowly focus
on their own ideas.
They get stuck on something -- you've met
them, right?
The technology changed ten years ago.
They're still beating the same dead horse,
you know?
Then, at the "hands" level, they can easily
become disconnected from the organization.
So, Luminaries think they've given a clear
hand-off.
"You know? I had this idea in the shower,
and I just thought we should do this -- if
we strung that together, put that with that,
got it?" Right?
I mean, it's just -- it's so vague, it's 50,000-foot
level.
And then, you're supposed to pick it up and
run with it.
So they often disconnect there.
And if you don't track with their ideas, they'll
just hit the "eject" button and find somebody
else who does like their ideas -- on a bad
day.
The Entrepreneurs -- they can chase stuff
that are nonexistent opportunities -- not
real opportunities.
And one of the things about Entrepreneurs
is, they don't have failures.
They just have "learning experiences."
That's what they call them. So they don't
learn from their mistakes.
And, they can also fake it on the "skills"
front.
Managers don't like to fake it; they like
to at least have one skill.
"I can do finance. I can do project management."
Entrepreneurs and some of the others can do
"anything," and then, they'll go and figure
out how to do it afterwards. Okay.
Managers -- they can sometimes lack spontaneity.
The other thing they can do is, they can become
a little bit rigid.
You see, here's the deal -- Managers write
the manuals, like the HR manual.
You go along, and you say, "I'd like to take
vacation to go to the Bahamas and then visit
my cousin over here.
It's like going to look like a 6-weeks [inaudible]."
"Paragraph 43, Subsection 2, you know, says,
'You can't do that until you've been at Google
for nine years.'"
And you didn't even know there was such a
thing.
Now, hint for the other people -- the Managers
write the rule books, but they don't necessarily
keep them themselves.
On a bad day, they just know when to bring
them out just to beat on the other people.
Okay. Organizers -- there's nothing that an
Organizer hates more than a calm pond.
So they get their excitement out of fighting
fires.
So if there isn't a fire, start one, right?
[laughter]
So when you go along and you've got a project
that's going fine, who needs an Organizer?
So they'll just create an issue, right?
And they'll just raise a problem.
If you've been out of the office for three
weeks and you want to know what's going on
and you got one phone call to make, like off
the island -- call the Organizer.
Because on a bad day, they're like the office
Velcro -- all the dirt sticks to them as they
go through.
And they can tell you exactly what's going
on.
And that's the counter-side of their intuition.
So, a little bit on the Networkers -- they
can have a poor Reality Index.
And I should mention the Reality Index briefly.
The Managers are at the middle, because they
have the best grasp of reality.
They're dead in the middle.
I remember one day, I was at home, and my
son was sitting at a computer looking at a
picture of his sister.
Off to the other side was my youngest son,
and my wife Lynn was making an urchin outfit
for him for "Oliver" for the play.
So he's dressed in rags.
I was exercising, which consisted of pulling
a rope over a door through a pulley -- a mechanism
designed for astronauts, because there was
no gravity up there, so they needed something
with resistance.
And my middle son announces, "This family
is whacked." [laughter]
And my wife, who's got a lot of Networker
in her -- Networkers like to be liked -- she
was aghast.
"What do you mean? What do you mean?"
I said, "Hold on. Hold on. James -- explain
to me, what do you have in mind?"
He said, "Well, I see every picture of my
sister -- she's smiling, but she's the most
complex person I know."
Then, there's Davy, who has no defense, because
he's wearing the rags.
And then, he looks at me -- I'm also, you
know, in a precarious situation.
I say to him, "James, you think you're the
only sane one in the family."
"Yep." Now, he's the air force pilot. He's
the jock.
He's the 97-percent left brain -- Steady Eddy.
And he thinks the rest of the people are whackos.
And that's the way Managers see things.
Their view of the world is reality, and out
in left field are the Networkers, er, Luminaries
and out in right field are the Networkers
-- and they're somewhat right.
[referring to projection] So [referring to
screen projection], this is just a quote from
one of our companies we work with and from
somebody at Cisco.
I'm going to move right along.
We have a LEMON Assessment.
It's pretty simple. We take 75 spots.
You don't have to write anything. No handwriting
analysis.
No references from your doctor.
All you do is put in the x's and we run the
analytics and what pops up is somebody like
"Ned Morgan" -- not his real name.
He's a Networker/Manager. Okay?
And what you understand about this person
is, when you look at their profile, you'll
get a sense as to how they think, what their
time horizons are, how they hear things when
you speak to them.
I'll give you an example in a moment.
You can also stack up the scores for a department.
So, this department is fine, if you're in
customer service.
If this department is R & D, you've got a
problem, because they don't have enough from
the Luminary side of things.
Obviously, you have to weight the data for
teams, and you can see somebody might be high
on scoring themselves, and somebody might
be low, but you can weight the data for the
teams.
The other thing that we look at is, What are
the primary and secondary slices?
So in a room such as this, if you ran the
assessment, there would be some people who
are primary Luminaries.
So over here, four primary Luminaries and
three secondary Luminaries.
We were working with an executive team once,
and out of 40-plus execs, not one primary
Entrepreneur.
Another company we worked with -- this was
in Indonesia -- they had a head office staff
of 120 people and this field, direct sales
staff of 250,000.
And they had one Entrepreneur in the head
office.
And out in the field, close to 250,000 Entrepreneurs.
You can imagine what the problems are going
to be.
They speak a different language. They do different
things.
So we had to teach the head office folks how
to speak like Entrepreneurs and Networkers.
You can't change how somebody's wired, but
you can change the way they speak.
So the next day, it was quite cute.
We had some of the corporate office staff
and the execs were manning the phones.
And there was the product development lead
-- VP of Product Development -- who's a Luminary,
talking like a real schmoozer on the phone
to somebody out there, because he figured
out how to speak their language and connect
with them.
So, let me give you a simple example.
When you ask somebody, "Is the project done?"
And they say to you, "It's finished," what
do they really mean?
Well, you better know who you're talking to.
Because, if a Luminary says, "It's finished."
Then what he means is, "I've thought about
it quite a bit.
You know, I might have written a white paper.
I e-mailed a few friends.
Conceptually, there's nothing standing in
the way of this thing getting done.
It's quite conceptually possible. In fact,
it's as good as done."
When you say to an Entrepreneur, "Is it finished?"
And they say, "Oh yeah, it's finished," what
they mean is, "It's like one of five things
that I'm working on at the moment. If it stays
up close to the top of the pile, I'll probably
push it through, but if a better opportunity
comes along, you're dead -- I'm not going
to finish it."
Now, when a Manager says, "It's finished,"
what does a Manager mean?
It's finished -- yeah.
Otherwise, they'll tell you, "It's 95 percent
complete.
And over the next two weeks, if you give me
additional resources, I'll finish it."
That's what the Manager says.
Now, when an Organizer says, "It's finished."
What they mean is, "It's about 70 percent
done, and that's all I'm going to do.
I'm not going to do anymore."
Because the other 30 percent, for an Organizer,
is a complete waste of time.
It's the last like 20 percent of a project
that takes 80 percent of your resources.
They learn that by instinct.
So when an Organizer says, "It's done" -- We
moved office once, and the whole move was
planned by two organizers.
I was in Hawaii. I got back, and it was incredible.
The whole thing was done in two days.
Except that, when you leaned against the cubes,
they weren't attached to the wall.
Everything looked like it was in place.
So I waited a week -- two weeks -- three weeks.
I figured, "At some point, somebody is going
to bolt the brackets to the wall, connect
everything, finish up all the stuff."
I was deluded.
I had two organizers working on the thing.
From their perspective, it was done -- the
phones worked, the printers worked -- that's
it.
Networkers -- when a Networker says, "It's
done," what he means is, "I got a friend.
My friend has a cousin, Billy.
And Billy -- Billy knows a lot of people,
and those -- I have five people that could
easily -- and if we had a party and brought
those people over, probably" -- It's, you
know, it's not done.
It's not even close to done.
So that's the way the Networkers think. [laughter]
So you got to know what you're thinking about.
So when you're speaking to somebody, you have
to figure out, How do they speak?
How do they hear things? How do they communicate?
so that you can put the communication in the
right context. Okay.
We had a situation with one company -- large,
huge IT organization within a large insurance
company.
And I saw, during the day-long discussion,
that two people were kind of looking at each
other.
Clearly, there'd been past issues.
So I invited them up for a role play. They
agreed.
And one was a Luminary/Organizer, uh, Luminary/Entrepreneur.
And the other was a Manager/Organizer.
And the guy -- I said, "Replay what happened."
He said to her, "I got this great idea for
a new business.
It's a brilliant idea. It's going to be fantastic.
Don't worry about the details."
He says to her. I said, "Pause right there."
I said to her, "What did you hear when he
said 'Don't worry about the details'?"
She said, "I heard 'There aren't any details.'"
Yeah.
So I said, "What was your response?"
She said, "Well, give me the functional specs
and the business plan -- the cost-benefit
analysis."
I said, "Hold on.
Mr. Luminary, what did you hear when she said
that?"
"Oh, you know, you may as well have told me
to walk on nails, jump in the fire, pour cold
water on myself. It was like the kiss of death."
We went back and forth, and I tried to get
them to speak each other's languages, which
they did.
You know, eventually, they killed the project
and it was a new business opportunity that
they killed.
But here was the telling thing -- I asked
the Manager/Organizer, "What probability of
success did you put on this venture?"
I had asked him the question first, Luminary/Entrepreneur.
He said, "85 percent." She said, "0 to 1 percent."
That's the gap when we don't understand how
people are wired and we don't adjust the communications.
Okay.
So I'm not going to speak about all the communications
overview.
Just to say -- before I take some questions
-- that there's multiple branches to the
LEMON Tree.
There's the LEMON Basics -- your characteristics,
strengths, weaknesses, how you're wired, what
you do for work.
There's also LEMON Communications -- I hinted
at that.
Product Development is another one.
If you're in HR, how do you make sure you
hire the right people?
Here's the thesis.
On any major project or on a leadership team,
you need all five slices of the lemon.
The problem is, we hire people who are like
us, for the most part.
We had a company in Texas, brought in a new
VP of Compliance.
You can guess, she's a Manager. And what did
she want to do?
Fire all of the non-Managers, because they
weren't like her.
Who did she need to turn the place around?
Not the Managers. She needed the Entrepreneurs
and the Organizers.
And so, hiring is important.
Team Building -- some other facets to the
LEMON Tree.
Now, just to sum up from a different angle
-- the LEMONs care about different things.
So what do Luminaries care about?
They care about ideas -- "Why?" "Why?"
The Entrepreneurs don't give a hoot about
"why," because ideas are a dime a dozen.
You can get those -- just go up the road to
Stanford or whatever.
You can get tons of ideas.
The question is, can you turn it into an opportunity?
And so, they care about "What?" And then,
"When?"
The Managers care about "How?"
Any fool can come up with an idea, but can
you actually implement?
Things haven't begun until there's a plan.
Now, Organizers -- they care about costs and
crises.
They care about "When/What."
So the best solution for an Organizer is the
quick solution.
And they like -- when you're talking to an
Organizer, they always want to bring things
to a close.
They hate loose ends.
I know some Organizers who can't go to bed
at night unless their unread e-mail is less
than one screen.
Whereas, that doesn't bother the Luminaries.
They have hundreds of them, right?
Networkers -- they care about "Who."
Look, they don't like people more than other
people.
But, they understand the people dynamics.
They understand that kind of relational capital.
So, in summary -- from your friends at Wertle
-- that's the summary of the whole book.
And -- oh, yeah -- here's a little quiz for
you.
You've got it if you understand how to ruin
the day of a LEMON.
It's pretty easy.
How would you ruin the day of a Luminary?
Any suggestions?
Audience: Details.
Brett Johnson: Oh yeah, give them a lot of
details -- that'll be good.
Audience: Invite them to a [inaudible] planning
session.
Yeah, okay -- so long as they don't have to
do too much, they wouldn't mind being there
for awhile. Okay.
How else would you ruin the day of a Luminary?
Audience: Kill their ideas.
Brett Johnson: Kill their ideas. There's a
better way.
What else would you do? Steal their ideas,
right? [laughter] That's great.
You can kill it, but if you can just take
it, put your name on the white paper.
Right?
They've slaved there three years thinking
in all their Google spare time, come up with
stuff, and you just say, "I've got a few friends
over here -- can we kind of add our names
on there?"
We had a guy who lived with us -- an intern
-- and then, we had a second intern.
And the intern would compose these flowing
reports and send them back overseas.
And Number 2 would just take them, change
a few names, and send them off again, right?
So, you can ruin a Luminary's day by stealing
their ideas. Right.
How about an Entrepreneur? How can you ruin
their day? Okay?
Audience: Steal their opportunities
Brett Johnson: Steal their opportunities.
Kind of great.
You put a sales guy onto an account.
"Okay, you're responsible for this." And they
work six months.
They get to know everybody -- their birthdays,
their dog's names -- everything.
Get the client in, and you reassign them,
right?
That's a great way to ruin.
Managers -- you can mess with their systems,
right? [laughter]
Just for the heck of it.
Now, Managers actually believe that other
people understand systems and just don't obey
them just to get up the manager's nose.
That's what Managers really think.
But, for the Managers -- I got to tell you
-- the Networkers don't even see the expense
reporting system unless they're really desperate
for money, you know?
And so, Organizers -- take away their leader.
You've heard, "Take me to your leader."
Organizers are most satisfied when they're
supporting a leader, often in the background.
But when you put a Manager between the Organizer
and the Leader, you'll ruin their day.
That's what happens in Washington, D.C.
These people you've never heard of -- they
get a Manager between themselves and the President,
and they write the "Kiss and Tell" books,
you know?
About this president or that president.
Networkers -- how can you ruin a Networker's
day?
Audience: Isolate them.
Brett Johnson: Isolate them.
That's a cool thing. Yeah.
They love to be with people, right?
Networkers have an uncanny ability to connect
the dots.
You're a normal person, and you think -- they'll
come to you, and they'll say, "Oh, Jean -- you
got to meet this friend of mine in London
and the other guy in Houston.
If the three of you get together, I know."
See?
Networkers have this belief, "If we get enough
smart people together in the room, then the
miracles are going to happen, you know?"
No agenda, nothing, very exciting for the
Networkers.
And the fact is, they're intuitive about that.
I hired my first intern. He was a Networker.
He came to me, and he said, "Oh, I've got
this friend. I met him playing soccer" and
this, that.
But this was his second opportunity.
His first opportunity was so flaky -- some
guy in Florida doing some harebrained thing.
So the second time he came, [phht] I didn't
even listen to him.
Eighteen months later, Michael Yang sold my
assignment for 685 million, you know?
We could have had a piece of that if I listened
to my Networker.
So, okay. So, that's it.
And I wanted to let you know that we do have
some books here.
And we're running low on the first edition.
But just for you guys -- within about 24 hours
-- as soon as Amazon gets their stuff together,
there'll be a second edition up on Kindle.
Just to let you know -- black and white and
boring, but there you go.
So, that's the story.
Thank you very much.
And I'll be happy to take questions at this
point.
[applause]
Brett Johnson: Go ahead.
Q: I'm wondering, you mentioned some of the
other Myers-Briggs and colors and some other
things, how do these five styles attract to
those? Are there similarities or ...?
Brett Johnson: Yeah. I see them as a complement.
Okay, so to repeat, the question is -- what
about DISC, Myers-Briggs, colors, dogs, otters,
lions, bears, all that kind of stuff.
How do they fit in?
And the reality is that I tell people that
"This is a complement to those things."
This isn't about styles.
So you can be an indirect Manager.
You can be an abstract or a concrete Luminary.
You can be an introverted Networker.
And one of the things I'd have to catch myself
doing is not judging a book by its color.
Not saying, "Oh, she's introverted, so she
can't be a Networker."
I really have to run the tests to see.
Or "He looks like my friend who's a Manager,
so he's a Manager."
No. And so, at the back of the book over here,
as you go through the book, you can build
up your own compass and profile.
And so, I've got a way to build up a profile.
And at the bottom are some of the complementary
things.
So I see it as a complement, not an "instead
of."
It's pretty simple to understand.
There's a VP friend of mine who's Head of
Product Development at a company down the
road over here.
And he sat down with his 5-year-old and 7-year-old
and they talked through LEMON Leadership.
And what they talked about is, "Is it fair
for the parents to discipline the two kids
the same, because one's a Luminary and one's
a Manager?" You know?
And stuff like that. So a kid can get it quite
easily at a basic level.
And at a more complex level, you know, there's
other layers too.
Other questions? [long pause] Going once...
Alanna.
Q: Give us another communication style.
Brett Johnson: Yeah, sure. The issue of "communications"
is that -- you'll be able to spot somebody
somewhat by the way they communicate.
Now, a friend of mine actually has come up
with a concept of "LEMON Bait."
So if you're in a room like this -- you're
dealing with a group of people.
You don't know what they are.
So he throws out a little bit of Luminary
bait.
"This research thing that somebody's been
working on in Google, and the screensavers
go on."
Nobody bites, you know?
Then, he throws out something about an opportunity.
"If we did this project together, we could
do a joint market and collaborate."
Nothing, right?
Then, you throw out and you say, "Our policies
and procedures, this is our budget, our timelines..."
and all the lights go on -- you're talking
to Managers, right?
And so, then the communication piece is -- you
can see over here the content, the format,
in other words the media that they use, the
way in which they express things.
Whether they talk about issues, opportunities
-- when I'm talking to somebody, I'm looking
out generally to see when their eyes light
up.
When I talk about ideas, do they light up?
When I talk about issues, do they light up?
When I talk about people?
For example, the language of Networkers is
stories.
So if you're talking to Networkers, you've
got to talk stories.
You know, they cry during the dog commercials.
They love a story. They love an underdog,
an overdog. Any kind of stuff.
They love -- so long as there's a story over
there, right?
Managers like facts.
So if you're a salesperson who's a Networker
and you're trying to convince a Manager, and
you tell more and more and more stories, their
credibility index just starts going down,
because the Manager is thinking, "This person
doesn't have the facts, right?"
If you're a Luminary, and you go in and somebody
doesn't buy what you're saying, you know?
You just make the vision bigger.
You make the searches intergalactic. You know?
You make the response times submilliseconds.
And so, you throw more vision at it, rather
than giving the person exactly what they need.
They just want to know, "What's the start
date, end date, resources," or whatever.
And so, on the communication front, you can
see by the way that people communicate -- if
you have a short amount of time with somebody,
you can pick up verbal cues which will tell
you how they're wired.
And that can be a super-useful thing.
And then, what you have to do is, rotate the
lemon.
As a leader, you have to figure out, "What
does this situation call for?" because you
might be a Manager/Networker, and the situation
calls for a Luminary/Entrepreneur.
Rotate the lemon.
It'll hurt a little bit, but you can do it.
This is a huge difference between LEMON Leadership
and other stuff where we say "Avoid your weaknesses."
I'm saying, "No, each of us can make an adjustment."
The only thing that's going to stop me behaving
more like one of the other slices is actually
me thinking my slice is better than their
slice.
"All LEMONS are equal, but some LEMONS are
more equal than others" -- That kind of mindset
will stop your rotating, you know?
And I'm saying, on any team, "Even if you're
missing -- you look at your team -- there's
six of you in a row, and you're missing an
Entrepreneur."
You can all put on your Entrepreneur hat,
and say, "How would an Entrepreneur look at
this? How would an Entrepreneur communicate
this? Etcetera."
Okay. One more, yeah.
Q: [inaudible]
Brett Johnson: Yeah. Okay -- so, are there
combinations that pose more challenges than
others? Yeah.
Well, at a broad level, if you're developing
people, or if you are one, one of the hardest
challenges is the growth part for an Organizer,
because they're so intuitive.
They function so highly out of intuition.
So how to get them to grow beyond their intuition
is a challenge.
It's also hard to follow Organizers when they're
at the head of a corporation.
Jack Welsh, for example, when he took over
at GE, I think he was an Organizer/Entrepreneur.
And his vision was pretty simple -- "Number
1 or Number 2 in any market -- otherwise,
you're out. End of story."
But at least he communicated that clearly.
If you're functioning highly off intuition,
a bit of a challenge there.
Other combinations, no.
There's no right or wrong answers.
You just have to understand your primary and
secondary slice.
And make sure you know when you're having
a bad day.
Because when you're having a bad day, you
can see -- you begin to function out of the
negatives -- the weaknesses of your secondary
slice -- and you just have to make adjustments.
That's super helpful to me.
On a good day, I'm a bright Luminary -- good
ideas, and so on.
On a bad day, I'm the Manager from hell, right?
And, you know, and I know what they should
be doing and I nitpick.
I don't build people up. I don't foster them.
I just kind of get nitpicky on the details.
But if I know I'm having a bad day, I can
go off and get a latte -- do something different
-- go take a walk or something, you know?
Yeah. I had a husband-wife combination.
He's an expert -- both of them -- in Myers-Briggs,
DISC, and all of that stuff in another country.
So I can talk about them.
And, they run a leadership development institute.
That's what they do.
He's a Luminary/Organizer. She's a Manager/Organizer.
The problem was, they were about to become
a statistic of couples that couldn't work
together. Why?
She thought she was doing all the work and
he was just having ideas.
And then, they would have a bad day and they
would both be in the negatives of Organizers.
Now, what they do is, they'll go play golf
if they're both having a bad day.
They'll stop the work. It's a waste of time.
And they figured out how to complement each
other and get the job done.
Good. Alanna, I think we're done on time.
Thank you very much.
[applause]